this is history of the World Part Two
for Hulu Mel Brooks you ever heard of
him there's no way that Mel Brooks is a
part of this
[Music]
I loved making history
of good comedy writing just Shakespeare
like it
yeah it Shakespeare in Love
no no not yet
pushing
great comedy performing end this war yes
Mr President
God damn it that is gonna be the worst
thing that's gonna happen to my head all
year Nick Kroll Ike Baron holes and
myself talked about how we saw the show
once we got that together we pitched
that to Mel Mel loved the idea Adolf
Hitler not giving the performance he had
hoped for tonight the master racism
looking so masterful you put
concentration camps in people's
countries you better be Flawless on the
ice Mel gave us such a great template in
the first movie it's more than just your
average sketch show we're telling these
bigger broader stories and also telling
short funny sketches as Mel himself once
said we're taking a look at history and
kicking it in the pants sorry boys one
of the really fun parts of the show is
calling folks what we're fans of or
friends with and asking them to come and
be part of it someone like Quinta
Brunson who had been like a huge fan of
for a long time Jay Ellis zazzy beads so
call me Jesus Christ Son of God some
call him broken corny Johnny Knoxville
texted me was like Mel Brooks is
massively important to me anything you
need you let me know Johnny plays
Rasputin which felt fitting because
Rasputin was famously impossible to kill
and so is Johnny
being able to work with those guys it's
bucket list stuff I gotta do mouth to
mouth I'd rather die
I just love getting into the saddle
again and history of the world was a
great opportunity to explore so many
aspects of history that have happened
since I did the first one
enjoy but don't I already got paid for
this
[Music]